so go into some of the details the
vehicle design and performance and I'm
gonna close over or just I'll only talk
a little bit about the technical details
in the actual presentation and then I'll
leave the the detailed technical
questions to the Q&A that follows this
is to give you a sense of size
it's quite big
and the funny thing is I think in the
long term the strips will be even bigger
than this I think this will represent
this will be relatively small compared
to the Mars interplanetary ships of the
of the future but it kind of needs to be
about the size because if in order to
fit a hundred people there abouts in the
pressurized section plus carry of the
luggage and all of the unpressurized
cargo to build propellant plants and
both everything from iron foundries to
pizza joints to you name it in there but
we need to carry a lot a lot of cargo so
it really needs to be roughly on this on
this order of magnitude because if we
say like be the same minimum threshold
for self-sustaining city on Mars or
civilization would be a million people
well and you can only go every two years
if you if you if you have 100 people per
ship that's 10,000 throws so I think at
least 100 people per trip is is the
right order of magnitude and I think we
actually may end up expanding the the
crew section and and ultimately taking
more like 200 or more people per flight
in order to reduce the cost per person
so it's 10,000 flights is a lot of
flight so you really want to help me I
think on the order of a thousand ships
it would take a while to build up to a
thousand ships and so I think if you say
when we reach that million person
threshold from the point of which the
first ship goes to Mars it's probably
served between 20 to 50 total Maas
rendevouz so it's probably somewhere
between there maybe 40 to 100 years to
achieve a fully self-sustaining
civilization on Mars
so that's the sort of cross section of
the ship and in some ways it's not that
complicated really the it's made
primarily of an advance of carbon fiber
the common part is tricky when dealing
with deep cryogens and and trying to
achieve both liquid and gas in
permeability and have and not have gaps
occur due to cracking or pressurization
that would make the come by the leaky so
this is this is a fairly significant
technical challenge to make deeply
cryogenic tanks out of carbon fiber and
it's only recently that the that we
think the carbon fiber technology has
done to the point where we can actually
do this with without having to create a
liner on the in some sort of metal liner
while the liner on the inside of the
tanks Richard add mass and complexity so
a particularly tricky for the hot
gaseous oxygen pressurization so this
this is going to be cautiously
pressurized which means that the fuel
and the oxygen we gasify them through
heat exchanges in the engine and use
that to pressurize the tanks
so we're guessed by the methane and you
static pressurize the fuel tank gas by
the upstream use that pressurize the
oxygen tank and this compares that this
is a much simpler system than what we
have with with Falcon 9 where we use
helium pressurization and we use
nitrogen for gas thrusters in this case
we were talking these torturously
pressurize and then use gaseous methane
and oxygen
the control thrusters so really only you
only need two ingredients for this as
opposed to four in the case of Falcon 9
and actually five if you consider the
ignition liquid so we use reserve like
it's sort of complicated liquid to
ignite the engines that that isn't is
very usefulness in this case we would
use spark ignition so this gives you a
sense of vehicles by performance sort of
cards and historic hope you can actually
read that but in expendable mode that
the vehicle personally would do about
550 tons and about 300 tons in reusable
mode that compares to the satisfy max
capability of 135 tonnes but I think
this this really gives a better sense
for things the light bars show the
performance of the vehicle like there
was the payload to orbit of the vehicle
so you can see essentially what it
represents is what's the size efficiency
of the of the vehicle
and most drugs including ours that our
apps are currently flying the speed
performance bar is only a small
percentage of the actual size of the
rocket but with the interplanetary
system with traditionally the use of
Mars we've been able to or we believe
massively improve the design performance
so it's the first time a rockets sort of
performance bar will actually exceed the
physical size of the rocket